and well last night was it oprah's
highly anticipated interview with prince
harry and meghan markle
on cbs there was so much to talk about
oh so much to talk about john it was two
hours long and man was it draw
chopping draw dropping jaw dropping
there we go prince harry said his
decision
to step away from the monarchy damaged
his relationship with his father
prince charles now at one point the
future king wouldn't even take his calls
he also talked about why he and megan
stepped away from the royal family
was the move about getting away from the
uk press because the presses you know
was everywhere
or was it a move because you weren't
getting enough support
from the firm it was both
both as harry said they were having a
really hard time with the british
tabloids
which megan says led to her having
suicidal thoughts
and she says the royal family dissuaded
her from getting help
because of how it would make them look
it
was all happening just because i was
breathing
and
look i was really ashamed to say it at
the time
and ashamed to have to admit it to harry
especially
um because i know how much loss he
suffered
but i knew that if i didn't say it
that i would do it and i i just didn't
i just didn't want to be alive anymore
and that was a very
clear and real
and frightening
constant thought oh man
another revelation involved the couple's
son archie
and accusations of racism megan also
said the royal family had concerns
about the color of archie's skin how
dark it might be
buckingham palace has not yet commented
on that interview
i'm sure they will at some point because
there was a lot to it 621 now you can
see
more about the interview on cbs this
morning oprah will join the program
to show even more new clips from her
chats with
harry and megan again that is cbs this
morning at seven o'clock
well worth tuning into